hmm did you ever try did you ever rap
for a little bit but I did it because it
was like a release like I liked it
because it you know what I'm saying like
I I can go talk my [ __ ] on it but like I
never really I feel like you'd be like a
natural dope rapper it was it was cool
man but you know trying to do it within
a group you know just with people or
things like that always been a good team
player you know what I'm saying like
always been like yeah just with some of
my people right right and just always
being a good team player but you know
[ __ ] don't always play like
that so you know things always you know
break up and I was just like man I just
I think it kind of beat me out of it
like I was like how many years were you
trying
probably like
three three years [ __ ] you're like three
yeah in Vegas yeah that Vegas rap scene
is lit bro I love it out there it's cool
I like about that the Ahab battles and
all that [ __ ] I feel like it gets robbed
of its shine too you know a lot of
cities do but if we're going to talk
about Vegas I feel like Vegas it gets
robbed of it I mean everybody that is
from there that that raps that even
knows of me knows I'm telling the truth
they get robbed of it they don't get the
same type of opportunities to go shut
[ __ ] down like getting calls like hey
we're taking nine of y'all 10 of y'all a
month let's get across the country ain't
nobody getting them [ __ ] phone calls
like that that's right and everything
that they probably getting is is coming
from out of town and then even the [ __ ]
you were saying like people don't know
like NEOS from Vegas have they went to
Rancho yeah they went to Rancho and like
I'm like yo you would never know that
because Neil don't really rep Vegas like
you know you know what I mean but it was
on his ID one time when he got pulled
over in a little prank like a little
[ __ ] right pulled out his ID and it says
why does it say North Las Vegas but he
was claiming La yeah he was like oh I
went to school there like nobody nobody
really I don't know I just don't get
that part of it bro like if you know
what I'm saying like I got love for
mandango and Vegas like but if you could
show some love man like don't
show some love let them know where you
from man let them know where your
background comes from but everybody
always try to hide it like they hiding
something especially I don't get that
part like you could tell your story like
why why hide something if you want to be
from La hey all right go ahead and say
hey I'm from here but by way of here do
whatever you do but just keep that [ __ ]
of bad